for today's classic interview were
really going back to a true classic this
was when one of the daughters of the
Westboro Baptist churches fred phelps
joined me but not the more well-known
Shirley phelps-roper rather it was
margie phelps and her demeanor was very
different than what we've become
accustomed to from shirley phelps roper
she also had a very different approach
as to how to insult me
you'll notice that Shirley phelps-roper
tended to insult me in one way and
margie phelps was in some ways more
lighthearted and also certainly more
creative this is what we refer to as the
infamous titmouse episode where she
referred to me as a titmouse we talked
about all sorts of stuff and as you saw
with Shirley phelps-roper as well as
with Jonathan Phelps the Apple never
felt too far from the tree as far as the
children of Fred Phelps and the Westboro
Baptist Church although since this
interview we've actually seen more of
the phelps grandchildren and also
there's the second family the drained
families we've interviewed Steve drain
before one of his daughters also
famously leaving the Westboro Baptist
Church known for their God hates
slogan so there is hope I mean the
grandchildren seem to be sort of opening
up their eyes to what is going on here
and also very famously Nathan Phelps who
is one of Fred Phelps his children he
separated years ago and has actually
become sort of like a free-thinking
secular activists and speaker who we've
also interviewed on the show so birth
today we'll go back to December of 2012
the infamous titmouse incident with
margie phelps of the Westboro Baptist
Church
joining me is margie phelps from the
Westboro Baptist Church immediately
after the shooting at Sandy Hook school
the Westboro Baptist Church announced
that it would be picketing the vigil as
well as I believe some of the funerals
Margie let's cut right to the chase
what's the reason do you still plan to
picket funerals and what's the reason
for that every time God reaches down
into this nation and smashing art and
gets your attention we're going to
Comfort the work that's our job
permission so one of the ways he's doing
that increasing it by these shooters
they're getting younger and their
numbers are getting bigger
we've told you for over twenty years we
keep up this path route 10 they're gonna
bring mayhem to the land and now you
back first and now you're in a fever for
to chase their same-sex marriage
Connecticut was one of the first states
to come out the things that's marriage
you guys think you can brute force away
the standard of God it's not gonna
happen you heard it here first
okay but Margie what's the plan would
end the plan with the funerals
specifically soon Connecticut is going
to look like a tea party many more
shooters many more deaths are coming and
the plan with Connecticut are you
kidding me there's already been
thousands of our words put out in the
airwaves will continue on the course
we're on that's why them okay but are
you going to pick at the funerals of the
kids wherever we can put these signs up
including those funerals it's what we'll
do
okay and specifically I mean I
understand that you believe broadly that
anything bad that happens in this
country is God's punishment for what you
consider to be the acceptance of
homosexuality but I mean these kids and
we have a lot of their pictures here I
mean what what did little Jack Pinto do
to deserve you Jonathan Phelps there
with a god-sent the shooter sign right
or I mean any any of these right you
know Olivia Engel what did she do what's
the point of being there truth is and
name them all those children are better
off yet and in this nation without every
child of that age in this nation outside
of Westboro Baptist Church is without
hope they are on their mother's milk
taught to be proud sinners and rebel
against the god of glory there's no hope
for those children you know wrong sense
worse they died look at your hands David
Pakman their blood is on your hands and
all the rest of the media and all the
rest of the
teachers and all the rest feeders their
blood is on your hand if you ever
cracked a Bible you would be familiar
with the fact that when you enrage the
King of glory the Lord God Jehovah he
comes on the scene with destruction and
he's no respecter of age he kills
infants in his wrath furthermore no one
is born innocence
so get off all that nonsense it's
maudlin it's unscriptural
it's unhelpful at the dock if you don't
want more of those dead children stop
what you're doing Margie there's enough
if you gave a rap backs on you or anyone
else in this nation if you really cared
Barack Obama we're gonna have to
disagree on this board for your sand
yeah you would change course before you
have thousands of dead laying at your
feet Margie I wanna let's ask if you
agree to disagree
no I know I know that I know the Bible
stuff but let's don't try to keep it
concise a little because there are more
things incredibly there is actually we
actually have a lot of things to talk
about with you I know that'll come as a
shock to a lot of people there have been
about 200 articles but just to be clear
the only thing you and I are talking
about today is Connecticut and same-sex
marriage don't waste my time
you don't have a big enough audience for
me to waste my time with anything you
know so I go off any rabbit trails no no
I'm gonna stick to that I thank you for
keeping me focused Margie because I want
to stick to another issue which is
several hundred articles are now out
about anonymous excuse me Margit let me
see if we can get a question in here if
I may anima irrelevant criminal cowards
whose names God knows and who will let
the criminal authorities deal with then
then that's when I use my Skype hang up
telephone so stick to the issue of today
the issue of today is Connecticut dead
children run for same-sex marriage and
we'll continue to chat but have you been
attacked by anonymous and they're
lurking in the background all the time
anonymous is there relevant they're
there so yesterday okay now me Wow
meanwhile
the real issue is if you could shut us
up if you could shut us up the Lord God
will find someone else to say these
words in fact Christ said you'll find
some stones I know he did so look for
the stones to start talking Margie I
wanna okay I bent the shoe and he's not
not give me an opportunity Margie to
talk to you one-on-one here let's look
III against my better judgment maybe I
want to maybe try to work out some David
you need is way worse than we need you
so stop all that market Anonymous is
irrelevant and off you forget about
anonymous for a second sure Margie I'm
sorry let's just look let me just can I
make a proposal to you will you listen
to a proposal from me is that and then
you can reject it or accept it it's your
choice it's not all any debt okay
my goal is to keep you and your signs
away from the funerals of these kids in
Connecticut and as you said your goal is
for as many people as possible to hear
your message which you have made a
number of times on this show so and I
may regret this and I think my audience
may not like this but what I want to
propose to you is would you be willing
to say you will stay away from the
funerals of the children in exchange I
would provide you a 30-minute
uninterrupted it won't be me
interrupting you and saying oh but what
about this and that we will give you 30
minutes really to put together it can be
a video that you put together or
whatever you want we'll put it on our
youtube channel which has 25 million
views we're on 160 TV and radio stations
across the country
we're on DirecTV and Dish Network in 32
million homes I know that my audience
will not like this but I feel like I may
be doing something good I would be
willing to compromise and offer you that
opportunity if you agree simply stay
away from the funerals of these few kids
and you'll reach way more people this
way which I don't like I really don't
but I just want to see if we can maybe
broker some kind of agreement okay so we
were hoping to hear back about whether
or not our proposal was accepted there
were a number of phone calls and trying
to connect with them interchange we
spoke
to their public relations person as of
now we have not gotten an answer they're
considering our proposal I'm very
hopeful that we've negotiated something
here to keep them away from those
funerals of those kids in Connecticut as
soon as we know more obviously we'll
present it to you and and I hope that
they will that they will do it I think
we'll have done something very good if
we can just keep them away from those
funeral